une scène difficile à regarder un bête
sang d'une rare intensité à la sortie
d'une synagogue dans ce quartier
généralement paisible de Jérusalem Est
ce serait une des pires attaques
terroristes des dernières années contre
des Israéliens a déclaré la police
locale
alors que des résidences qu'en dmord au
terroristes le Premier ministre
israélien Benyamine Nintendo s'est rendu
sur les lieux
selon le chef de la police d'Israël la
saillant sera arrivé seul sur place vers
20h15
et aurait réussi à prendre la fuite
avant d'être rattrapé et tué par les
forces de l'ordre
il faut dire que les tensions sont vives
depuis que 9 Palestiniens ont été tués
hier lors d'un raid militaire israélien
Jordanie territoire occupés par Israël
le réel qui a également fait des
dizaines de blessés cibler le groupe
Djihad islamique qui aurait planifié une
attaque en Israël
en guise de représailles des roquettes
ont été tirées à partir de Gaza des
gestes qui s'inscrivent dans une montée
de la violence qui perdure depuis près
d'un an à telle cette expert il faut pas
s'arrêter au fils qui peuvent paraître
encore une fois dérisoires par rapport à
des conflits dans le monde nous on a
quand même le conflit le plus long et
dont on ne voit pas la fin
l'année dernière a été la plus sanglante
en Israël et dans les Territoires
Palestiniens depuis 2004 ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]